sometime around the middle of November I
was approached by Ubisoft to see if
hypothetically something came up
that I'll be interested in okay with
overseas travel but before they were
able to tell me anything about it
I'd have to sign an NDA select the grown
up adult that I am I studied this
document word for word and even had some
of the legal counsel at my office cast
their eyes over it before signing and
sending back to Ubisoft well that's what
I should have done in reality I was so
excited to see what this is all about I
briefly skimmed over it before signing
and immediately sending it back while
hyperventilating over my computer until
I got a response yes so went over it in
more detail and Headley will have a look
but this was well after the fact I was
chosen alongside skillet to represent
the Australasia region in a media /
influencer hands-on testing bin at
massive entertainment in Sweden for the
PvP of the upcoming game the Division
two
[Music]
you
firstly you must understand this is all
very crazy for a little channel like us
to be sent along to an event like this
so long so much bigger players in the
industry likes Killa Eric's and Marco
Styles so was hard not to be excited but
I understood from the start that it
wasn't just a free trip to Sweden I was
there to do a job we were there to test
the most up-to-date playable version of
the PvP side of the game including the
new dark zone and conflict modes
skirmish and domination and then once
the NDA embargo date was up to release
information regarding our thoughts and
feelings to our communities now I need
to clear this up right now
we were under no obligation to share
only positive opinions about the game I
don't post a lot but I'm all over read
it in Twitter and I've seen a lot of the
comments that have come up about this
event I've seen all the talk about the
free trip and how it could be a way to
influence the outcome of how the people
sent over would feel about the game but
this just isn't the case for most people
have sent over there arrived the night
before and we're back on the plane by
the end of the day after the event it's
not like they were sent on a two-week
holiday it was very well structured and
there was limited time to do anything
outside of the proposed timetable that
we're all sent beforehand especially for
those of us that weren't transit over 30
hours one way to make it to the event in
this video I'll be talking about my
experience on this trip covering the
wider timetable behind this event and my
thoughts and feelings based on what was
presented to us in the following videos
that I'll release over the next day or
so are going to further detail on the
PvP gameplay and skills that were played
and tested out the general timetable
went something like this
I think I probably had the furthest way
to come so my flights were a little more
complicated to organize for this reason
I actually ended up in Sweden a good day
and a half before everyone else for
example my trip on the way to the venue
had me catching a plane from Auckland at
New Zealand from 4 p.m. flying for 18
hours
arriving in Doha hanging around there
for a couple of hours catching another
seven hour flight to Stockholm so I was
finally in Sweden but I had a couple of
hours of hanging around to catch my last
1 hour flight to Malmo god I wish I
could sleep on planes
[Music]
anyway I eventually made it to my hotel
which happened to be a two minute walk
away from massive studios at this stage
I had a couple of days to burn before
the event I won't bore you with the
details but summing up Sweden is a
beautiful country they'll definitely be
back someday to do some more exploring
on December 13th all of the youtubers
streamers and other social media
influences met up in the reception area
at massive we were then herded into a
side meeting room when they gave us an
up-to-date overview of the division -
and what we would be covering during our
stay there are some things the vast is
not to talk about due to them either
being not 100% finalized or wanting to
keep some surprises for the final game
so there may be some gaps in some of the
information a cover of the next few
videos the presentation was relatively
brief and their words would rather get
you guys playing the game as soon as
possible but essentially they went over
the new dark zone and general PvP
changes the map and its diverse variety
of location types and a brief overview
of the new clan system that will be
implemented into the game I'm not going
to talk about the dark zone in PvP as
I'm covering that in the next video but
I will say that each area we were put
into had a vastly different fields to
the last offering a number of different
approaches one thing that I would like
to flag early on is that they talked
about a number of changes that have been
introduced that it pretty much comes
solely from the feedback they've
received from the players and the
Division one communities while this was
super refreshing to hear and immediately
brought me back to the earlier days of
the division where multiple changes were
applied due to some of the noisier
groups on forums and Reddit and these
impacted the game negatively in the long
run one of mentioned time and time again
is when they make gear easy to get
essentially removing the grind and any
feeling of reward when hunting for gear
which hugely impacted the RPG feel of
the game the majority of the feedback
changes have been based around the more
toxic side of the game the dark zone
although I understand what they've done
us I think they may have changed some of
the things that have made the dark zone
what it is a no-man's land where
anything could happen but I'll talk more
about this soon something a lot of
people have been talking about is clans
I know there's a lot of people in my
community looking forward to it
unfortunately I can't give you too much
info on this right now all we know right
now is that has been set up for waiters
to quickly be able to find people to
play with it's sort of like an
extensions of a friends list that's
super easy and quick to navigate
on top of us there will be some some
unclaimed ranking or challenge system
that will allow the more active and
competitive members of the clan to strut
the stuff I'm definitely looking forward
to finding out more information on us we
have a pretty awesome discord channel
but I see this is an in-game extension
to it no idea on Clan numbers at the
stage and whether an inter clan
competitive system will be implemented
but the way they've set it up does give
the feel that they'll be keeping things
quite open to allow for easy additions
later on after the presentation we were
then shuffled to the other side of the
massive building pun intended we will be
split into teams of four in separate
into different rooms each rig was set up
ready first to start straightaway one
thing to note is that we were on
consoles Xboxes and I'll be the first to
admit that after 12 months on PC I'm a
little rusty on controller here is very
shamelessly name-drop who was teamed up
with in a squad there's a couple of
spanish players who are having a few
issues with understanding me not that
surprising really there are a number of
english-speaking countries that struggle
to understand what I'm trying to say but
also in the room was Marco style and a
lot of my earlier videos I reference
Marco as most of them were about
simplifying some of the more intricate
details of the game it's more easily
digestible format for beginners and
people new to the RPG genre but don't
worry guys as much as I was fangirling
out at this whole situation awesome I
totally played it cool
long story short Marco and I are totally
BFFs now hello
it's me the first thing I noticed about
the game is that it was beautiful it
reminded me of the detail we saw in the
very first unveiling of the division 1
there were so many extra pieces added
that it really gave the feel that the
city had been completely neglected and
unmaintained for a long time
the location was a mess and although
much like a cover shooter than the first
game the cover didn't feel as obvious it
was better integrated into the world
around us another piece that stood out
to me was the character control I was a
little worried about talking to this
point because it had been a while since
I played for any extensive time on a
console but as soon as I made a home I
pushed my wife out of the way and jump
straight onto the Xbox to run a few
missions and I can confirm that the
control of the agent feels a lot more
smooth and natural than the previous
iteration of the game even still I
played like an absolute Muppet missing
shots left right and center running into
walls so getting freaked up by the
wildlife running around but I really
didn't want to waste any time playing
with game cities weapons feel a lot
different again it was a little hard to
compare to a mouse and keyboard straight
away and I did have to do some testing
when I got home but the handling was
quite new but in a good way
it felt natural on the controller I
still found myself gravitating to the
SMGs even more so than the assault
rifles but I did notice that I was doing
a hell of a lot less damage over medium
to long range had a little bit of a play
with some of the attachments to help
with some of the other weapons but again
I tried not to spend too much time on
this however the new attachment system
made me feel like there was a lot more
options to go for with the whole
positive negative aspect of each piece
one of the biggest pieces owns worried
about coming into this event due to a
number of other sequels of played over
the years was did it still feel like the
division and yes with all of the changes
I can honestly say it still feels like
the game I know in love there are new
mechanics the weapons feel a little bit
different and the enemies move a little
more unpredictably but it still feels
like the division
as fast as it started our time was
suddenly up we did spend a bit of time
mingling with the other influences and
Ubisoft employees from around the world
but then we had a bit of a tour around
the building the place is huge
but as our guide was telling us they've
outgrown it with 600 plus employees they
now had plans to move into a new complex
one that would take up an entire city
block the most memorable part of the
tour was probably the sound studio
although they had exactly what you'd
expect with the equipment and specially
designed recording rooms
it was the extents that gone to to make
the sounds that we take for granted
ingame sound as realistic as possible
for example in order to get that eerie
dead silence in the dark zone they spent
time recording in Chernobyl one of the
guys in our group asked the completely
reasonable question of well if you just
needed silence why not just record
nothing why go all the way over to
Chernobyl and they answered but if you
wanted to get the sound of a rock being
dropped or a can being kicked over in a
completely empty City there was simply
no better place on earth to get the
sound they went on to talk about how
they spent weeks in Washington DC to
make sure that sounds that were being
used were reverberating correctly off
the wall since certain buildings around
the city that would see in-game nothing
was left to chance it was now after 2:00
p.m. and the event was wrapping up
although had been there for more than
six hours it felt like we'd only just
gotten started we said our goodbyes and
I hit it up for lunch with a lovely Jake
from Ubisoft Australia before jumping on
my flights home I had a decent amount of
time to talk to you the soft and massive
employees both before the event at the
hotel and Juran but not Hamish my
long-lost brother we both missed each
other dammit but the one thing that
really stuck out to me was how much
these people really love their jobs and
the companies they work for and my day
job I deal with a lot of larger
companies and I think I'm pretty good at
getting a read on people I certainly
wasn't expecting the bible's kidding and
it wasn't just that they were struggling
to understand me they genuinely loved
what were they were doing and who they
were doing it for it was a real family
vibe and I'm not just talking about the
wonderful Kim and Jake from Ubisoft
Australia who have spent a number of
months talking to but everyone I was in
contact was this might just be me being
an old man thinking about the number of
terrible large companies I've worked for
in the past but it does make a huge
difference to how I perceive the brand
and the product they produce
as I said earlier and the next couple of
videos are dive into greater detail on
what was being tested and thanks to
Marco yep see name-dropping again I was
really able to get into some further
depth believe it or not this was a
shortened version of this video I spent
a lot of time googling over the
countryside of the beautiful Sweden but
an attempt to keep this a more concise
and to the point of the trope I cut out
a lot of the waffle I need to thank a
few people now because without you I
certainly would have been presented with
this amazing opportunity so thank you to
my community especially the ones that
really hold it all together and keep
things positive and techne along you
know who you are if you made it this far
thank you for watching and I hope to see
you in the next one where we geek out a
little more on the finer details of what
we tested at the division 2 event at
massive entertainment in Malmo Sweden
Cheers
[Music]
you